oh is it the proprietor the proprietor
the owner to our customer support at
your service
so I actually spent the last 15 minutes
selling your new features uh yeah on the
podcast pretty exciting well the the
like the views are like incredible yeah
I mean and I saw Dave Rubin already made
an observation that if you look at New
York Times their views are maybe one
tenth Like My Views just me as a lone
Tweeter and he said that their followers
are inflated by just basically buying a
bunch of follower accounts yeah the
views thing is huge that's why I I
pushed the views which is like actually
a lot harder feature to implement than
you'd think because the sheer number of
uh transactions uh per second like uh
it's I think it sort of requires
system-wide on the order of of three
three million transactions a second to
actually calculate the view to you know
calculate and display the view count FYI
for Twitter Twitter Global so it's like
three million per second
it's a lot for those of you listening uh
Elon Musk has joined the Pod Elon how's
uh how's the first six weeks been
generally speaking of owning Twitter
well it's been quite a roller coaster
which uh obviously you've um but
witnessed and been on the roller coaster
as well yes the Dramamine I've taken the
Dramamine it's it's quite happening yeah
I mean it's exciting uh but I think it's
sort of
has its highs and lows to say the least
um but overall that seems to be going in
a good direction and um you know we've
got the the expenses reasonably under
control so the company's not like
on the in the fast lane of bankruptcy
anymore
and we're uh releasing features uh
faster than Twitter's history at the
same time as having contained the costs
and and uh reduced the cost structure by
a factor of three maybe maybe four so
you know the the verified uh is
obviously that's that's that's huge it's
a revenue stream as well as
um uh a means of
identifying of like knowing that it's a
real person and not a body or trial
situation
the having the affiliation organization
affiliation which I suspect you talked
about that was a an idea of David's that
was great
um to uh you know have organization
affiliation so you can know that
somebody is
um an actual professor at Stanford or uh
that this particular handle is actually
Disney not someone simply putting I work
at Disney in my in their bio
so um I think that's going to be really
helpful it they're just really just
having um detailed and uh nuanced
verification so of all the various
things that you say you are are these
things validated by other people and
organizations